comment les entreprises peuvent changer
le monde merci de la pour vous dire
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue
sur l'île de Pâques
vous êtes à 3500 km des coachs
perdus en plein milieu du Pacifique sud
vous êtes dans un des endroits les plus
isolés de la planète
et si vous fermez les yeux vous pouvez
sentir sur vos visages les embruns qui
viennent également caresser les visages
des moaï que vous voyez derrière ces
gigantesques statut de tube volcanique
voici projeté donc au XVIIe siècle
dans la civilisation des matamora la
civilisation des matamua était une
civilisation florissante à bien des
égards ils avaient une culture unique
qui a développé une langue une écriture
des rythes religieux des pratiques
artistiques
on retient également des maths à moi
une très grande ingéniosité et un très
grand savoir-faire qu'on retrouve dans
des structures qu'ils ont développé des
structures en terrasse pour leur
plantation des structures en pierre pour
soutenir les moai que vous voyez
derrière et également des structures
très sophistiquées d'irrigation pour
canaliser et guider l'eau douce sur
l'île
les maths et donc une civilisation
florissante mais qui malheureusement a
commencé à péricliter
et une des théories qui explique ce
déclin et une théorie d'effondrement de
l'écosystème de l'île de Pâques et donc
d'effondrement de la civilisation
cette civilisation beaucoup plus récente
connaissait une démographie grandissante
de plus en plus de gens sur l'île
nécessitaient d'accélérer l'agriculture
et en accélérant l'agriculture les maths
à moins ont commencé à défricher
entièrement l'île d'effort est
entièrement
plus d'arbres ça voulait dire accélérer
également l'érosion des sols les sols se
sont retrouvés lessivés perte de
fertilité des sols effondrement de la
biodiversité
plus tard c'était également plus de
maison plus d'outils plus de bateaux
pour aller pêcher
plus d'arbres c'est également plus de
ressources en eau potable parce que les
arbres captent l'eau douce qui permet de
reconstituer les nappes phréatiques
souterraines
dans ce contexte donc de démographie
grandissante et de chute des ressources
naturelles à la fois ressources de
nourriture ressources d'eau
naturellement ont émergé des conflits
qui ont provoqué le déclin
d'assivilisation alors si cette thèse de
l'effondrement c'est une thèse qui est
assez controversée
il y a par ailleurs certaines autres
éléments dont pour le coup on est
certain c'est que l'arrivée des colons
blancs au 18e siècle
à achevé le déclin de la civilisation
matamua en apportant avec elle
de l'esclavage et des maladies exotiques
alors cette histoire histoire des maths
à moi c'est une histoire qui est
intéressante parce que elle nous permet
aussi de se poser la question nous où on
en est de notre civilisation
où on en est de notre écosystème
l'entreprise a une place prépondérante
d'un autre civilisation
occidentale capitaliste c'est grâce à de
nombreuses entreprises que notre mode de
vie s'est amélioré que nous conditions
de vie se sont améliorées mais c'est
aussi du coup d'une certaine manière à
cause des entreprises qu'aujourd'hui on
rencontre tout un tas de défis des défis
sociaux environnementaux
un des défis environnementaux d'abord
une accélération des catastrophes
climatiques à l'accélération à la fois
en termes de fréquence mais aussi en
termes d'intensité des cyclones des
inondations des sécheresses des
incendies
chute également de la biodiversité en
vingt ans les campagnes françaises ont
perdu un tiers de leur population
d'oiseaux
augmentation également de la pollution
pollution un peu hosphérique mais
également pollution des sols il y a
quelques semaines une enquête du monde
révélait près de 17000 sites contaminés
en Europe contaminés par des polluants
éternels des pfas que l'on retrouve
notamment ici à Lyon
en plus de ces problèmes
environnementaux on trouve des défis
d'ordre social
je pense d'abord à la santé mentale je
sais pas si vous le savez mais
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises en
France il y a près d'un salarié sur
trois qui se vit en situation de burn
out
c'est un chiffre qui est absolument
inédit et malheureusement c'est un
chiffre qui est encore en croissance
en plus de ce burnout il y a également
des inégalités qui prospèrent
et notamment des inégalités femmes
hommes et des inégalités de salaire en
France en 2023 a tant de travail égal
les femmes sont encore payées en moyenne
15% de moins que les hommes
alors on peut se dire mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette civilisation qui détruit
le tissu social le tissu environnemental
qui est le fondement même de la vie de
l'homme sur terre
qu'est-ce que c'est que ces stratégies
d'entreprises qui a force de vouloir
rechercher de la croissance à tout prix
en réalité finissent par précipiter la
perte de la civilisation et donc la
perte même de leur modèle économique
alors la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il y a
des entreprises qui décident de faire un
pas de côté
ces entreprises on les appelle des
entreprises régénératives
régénérer le trésor de la littérature
française
de la langue française nous donne une
idée une définition qui est assez
intéressante
reconstitue un tissu un organe une
partie détruite naturellement ou
accidentellement
il s'agit donc pas de venir réduire
l'empreinte environnementale ou même la
neutraliser mais au contraire essayer
d'avoir un impact positif net sur la
nature sur l'environnement sur la
société
s'agit pas de venir réduire ses
émissions de carbone ses émissions de
CO2 il s'agit d'avoir des émissions de
carbone négatives
alors ces entreprises régénératives
elles existent déjà et je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui de deux exemples
la première c'est une entreprise qui
s'appelle interface interface vous ne
connaissez peut-être pas le nom
c'est pourtant une entreprise très
importante c'est le leader mondial des
revêtements de sol modulables ce sont
eux qui font les carrés les dalles de
moquette les dalles de vinyle les dalles
de caoutchouc sur lequel vous marchez
c'est une entreprise importante une
entreprise multinationale qui réalise
chaque année autour d'un virgule deux
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires et qui emploie dans le monde
3600 personnes
alors interface est une entreprise
régénérative
pourquoi alors tout d'abord c'est la
seule l'unique entreprise de son secteur
qui arrive à avoir
un impact aujourd'hui carbone neutre et
ce certifié par des organismes tiers
indépendants
et il ne s'arrête pas là ils ont un
programme
ambitieux qui leur permettra de devenir
carbone négatif à partir de 2040
comment est-ce qu'ils y arrivent alors
ils y arrivent en mettant en principe en
mettant en place des principes de
l'économie circulaire
d'abord en termes de sourcing des
matériaux
50% des matériaux que l'on retrouve dans
les produits qu'ils vendent sont des
matériaux
issus du recyclage ou des matériaux
biosourcés
ensuite ils mettent en place des
principes
déco design déco conception des produits
faut savoir que d'habitude quand on pose
de la moquette il y a à peu près 14% de
perte sur la moquette qu'on pose parce
que la moquette doit se poser dans un
sens interface a développé un système de
moquette qui peut être posé dans
n'importe quel sens et rien que ce
système leur permet de réduire les
chutes de 14% à 1,5%. interface c'est
également inspiré de la nature mettant
en place des pratiques de biomimétisme
et notamment en regardant comment les
pattes du gecko le gecko vous connaissez
c'est ce reptile qu'on le retrouve
souvent dans les pays chauds qui
grimpent au mur qui grimpent au plafond
et qui a une extrêmement bonne adhérence
aux pattes interface c'est donc inspiré
des pattes du gecko pour concevoir des
dalles que l'on pouvait poser enlever
repositionner le tout sans colle donc
sans solvant améliore la qualité de
l'air et prolongeant par la même la
durée de vie des produits
par ailleurs ils ont mis en place un
grand dispositif de récupération de
réutilisation et de recyclage des dalles
usagées
en plus d'interface qui a un impact du
coup environnemental régénératif je vais
vous parler de burzorg en pardonnez-moi
pour l'accent c'est une société
Néerlandaise créée en 2006
une société qui réalise des soins
infirmiers à domicile
l'originaire réalité de cette société de
cette entreprise c'est qu'elle crée un
peu partout dans les Pays-Bas des petits
groupes d'infirmiers 5 à 12 infirmiers
très ancrés dans le local
qui fonctionne avec une extrêmement
grande autonomie de gestion de prise de
décision et qui partagent leur bonne
pratique à d'autres groupes via les
réseaux internes de l'entreprise
alors burger c'est une société également
régénératrice régénératrice là beaucoup
du tissu social
comment est-ce qu'ils font ça 1 il
décide de replacer le patient au cœur du
système de soins avec une approche
holistique du patient en considérant le
patient pas unique au-delà de ses
besoins physiologiques mais aussi en
prenant en compte les besoins humains
relationnels que rencontrent les
personnes âgées
ce qui veut dire que le soin pratiqué
sur un patient va de pair avec la
qualité de la relation soignant patient
qui va être développé
et ça c'est à quelque chose de magique
ça permet de venir autonomiser les
patients et donc finalement on va passer
davantage de temps au début avec le
patient mais très rapidement le nombre
d'heures passées avec le patient va
décroître si bien que le système burza
permet d'économiser quasiment 50% du
temps normalement prodigué pour des
soins
alors burger c'est une entreprise qui
prospère également qui a connu une
accélération folle au Pays-Bas et
aujourd'hui dont les modèles sont
répliqués un peu partout dans le monde
et c'est une entreprise qui a des taux
de satisfaction de patients
incroyables
des taux de satisfaction également du
personnel complètement dingue
et par ailleurs une entreprise qui est
une entreprise très productive
c'est près de 40% de gains de
productivité
un grand cabinet d'audit a estimé que le
système social des Pays-Bas réalisé
grâce à burza une économie de près de
40% sur les soins prodigués dans le pays
donc c'est quelque chose de colossal et
ces deux exemples illustrent des
économies des entreprises régénératives
il en existe évidemment une multitude
d'autres mais on peut déjà avec ces deux
exemples essayer de d'identifier des
traits des caractéristiques communes à
ces entreprises régénératives
la première caractéristique c'est la
mission
la mission c'est remettre au coeur de
l'entreprise
le projet social et environnemental
et ça c'est quelque chose d'assez
magique parce que ça va venir donner une
nouvelle dimension à l'entreprise ça va
venir lui donner une boussole qui va lui
permettre de se guider et d'orienter les
décisions stratégiques qu'elles devront
prendre
pour burza c'est remettre le patient au
cœur du système de soins bien au-delà de
la simple réalisation de l'acte de
soigner
deuxième caractéristique c'est
l'innovation
en effet ça peut sembler paradoxal mais
ça nécessite énormément d'innovations
d'innovation à la fois technique mais
d'innovation également de conception
pour mettre en place des nouveaux
produits des nouveaux services qui
viennent répondre à la fois à des enjeux
sociaux à des enjeux environnementaux
mais aussi prendre en compte l'équation
économique nécessaire
l'innovation c'est pour interface
investir en recherche et développement
pour concevoir des dalles inspirer des
pattes du gecko pour concevoir des
dalles de moquette qui aujourd'hui ont
un impact positif sur l'environnement
enfin le troisième point c'est
l'expérience collaborateur
l'expérience collaborateur c'est à dire
remettre le collaborateur au centre de
l'entreprise
comprendre que l'entreprise Prospera si
elle sait prendre soin de son
collaborateur prendre soin de sa santé
mentale mais également de sa sécurité
physique
l'expérience collaborateur c'est chez
burzork réussir à remettre également
l'infirmière au centre du soin qu'elle
réalise non pas comme un robot qui
réaliserait mécaniquement des soins mais
au contraire en la responsabilisant en
lui donnant du poids de l'autonomie de
la capacité à décider pour elle-même de
la gestion de son fonctionnement de ce
qu'il y a à faire pour soigner au mieux
les patients
alors ces trois caractéristiques la
mission
l'innovation l'expérience collaborateur
sont des caractéristiques extrêmement
importantes pour n'importe quelle
société
tu as fait 10 ans que je conseille des
entreprises sur leur stratégie et le
déploiement de leur stratégie
finalement venir intégrer des principes
d'économie régénératrice permet à ces
entreprises de construire des stratégies
différenciantes de construire des
avantages compétitifs durables
alors maintenant vous allez me dire
super
mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
construire des entreprises régénératives
alors vous en doutez
c'est pas avec ça qu'on va construire
des entreprises régénératives c'est pas
avec des listes entières d'un
indicateurs clés de performance qu'on va
réussir à résoudre les problèmes du
siècle
c'est pas en remplissant des cases d'un
excès qu'on va répondre au défi du
changement climatique et au défi sociaux
moi ce que je propose c'est plutôt
d'essayer de faire un pas de côté et de
se dire finalement ces entreprises
régénératives qu'est-ce qu'elles ont en
commun
c'est qu'elles arrivent à mettre du
coeur
elles arrivent à mettre du coeur dans
leur mission elles arrivent à mettre du
coeur dans l'innovation du cœur à
l'ouvrage parce qu'évidemment c'est un
exercice difficile mais fonctionner
ainsi en environnement plus contraint
leur permet d'innover d'autant plus
elles arrivent à mettre du coeur
également dans l'expérience
collaborateur de la générosité dans le
soin qu'elles vont porter pas juste à
leur client pas juste à leurs
investisseurs mais également à leurs
employés
alors maintenant moi ce que je vous
propose la moralité finalement cette
histoire c'est que plutôt que d'avoir
une approche reporting RSE
de développement durable
essayons de penser ensemble un pacte
impact positif de l'entreprise sur la
société sur l'environnement et du coup
sur ses collaborateurs également
maintenant c'est à vous jeune leader
futur manager dirigeant
de mettre du cœur dans vos vies
professionnelles
c'est à vous de remettre du coeur dans
l'entreprise parce que c'est ainsi que
vous arriverez à répondre au défi socio
au défi environnementaux du siècle merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]